wichtig ist uns dass jemand der bei uns
arbeiten möchte mir liebe hat zu
hilfsbedürftigen menschen und
pflegebedürftigen menschen haben
begeisterung im team hat auch zu
arbeiten gemeinsam dinge anzugehen
partie man muss sich wirklich in die
lage der leute hineinversetzen können um
sie dort abzuholen wo sie auch stehen
man muss wirklich flexibel sein
kein tag ist wie der andere
offen für neue dinge sein und vor allem
auch bereits ein ja neue dinge zu lernen
man soll das entwickelt sich einfach
immer weiter gibt die möglichkeit
ungelernt in der pflege zu beginnen
da braucht man dann gewissen zeitraum
kommen erfahrungen sammelt und dann kann
man sich halt auch weiterbilden in dem
bereich die ausbildung dauert insgesamt
drei jahre
die dinge die man in der ausbildung
lernt sind einmal die anatomie des
menschlichen körpers die
krankheitsbilder sind ganz wichtig dann
vor allem die pflege wie westerland
patienten worauf kommt es an haut
beobachtungen als solche dinge und ein
wichtiger punkt ist die kommunikation
und die gesprächsführung wie man
wirklich mit den leuten umgeht und
sprich auch angehörigenarbeit meistens
deswegen eine altenpflegeausbildung auch
schon fachabitur verbunden so dass man
sogar nach der ausbildung studieren
könnte ansonsten gibt's vor den stränden
dass man sich zum experten entwickelt
was zum beispiel wunsch management
angeht palliativpflege oder halt in
richtung leitung pflegedienstleitung um
dann halt auch verantwortung zu
übernehmen ist im bereich einer ganzen
bereich durchzuführen
das wichtigste für mich ist immer
wirklich den patienten individuell zu
sehen sie so zu respektieren wie er ist
wir kommen als gast sein in science in
seinem eigenheim genau holen ihn dort ab
wo er steht das ganz ganz wichtig und
vor allem nötigen zu tun die auch
wirklich mir der beruf macht spaß weil
das ein beruf ist wenn man ganz viel
zurückbekommt bei jedem patienten
bekommt man entweder ein dankeschön oder
zumindest ein lächeln auf dem gesicht
und das mit einem ganz viel zurück
der beruf macht sinn man weiß eigentlich
was man getan hat wenn man nach hause
geht es fehlt ein
genau das war nochmal so die dinge die
ich mir als ziel gesetzt habe als ich im
büro vergabe genau die mich einfach auch
zufrieden stellen
am ende des tages